we are with the a-time national champion
Grandmaster Irina Crush after a very
important Victory Arena welcome back to
the show this was a difficult game she
was all over you after the opening did
you feel the same way yeah I mean this
was definitely I think one of my hardest
games here I mean it's actually maybe
the only game where I didn't get a great
position out of the opening
um I didn't feel like it was terrible
but maybe because my lack of knowledge
of this line
um yeah so this move she played D5
um I mean I had seen that that was a
possibility I just didn't evaluate the
position of so bad for black like I see
the the edge of the computer is giving
here I definitely did not uh think it
was so bad so uh let's go let's play a
few moves and it wasn't that bad
especially if she doesn't make the very
precise moves such as A4 and things of
that nature I mean it just seemed okay
like uh like her strategy was ambitious
with D5
um but you know I have this blockading
night I have a lot of problems to solve
like the bishop on B7 is not great
um but yeah like I still felt like this
this part was okay so the thing is that
she you know I was quite uh I think I
really should thank Nazi for playing
very ambitiously in this game because it
was clear that you know she wanted to
play it safer she could have she had
many opportunities to do that and the
fact that she kept trying to beat me you
know until the end that's kind of like
what backfired right it's what gave me
some chances
um you know but yeah she she really did
try to let's keep going you're talking
about this moment when you play the move
B5 yeah
yeah lots of moments like even if we go
back a little bit like you know when she
has this choice of which
right like I
right of course you know she could take
an F6 and I mean I didn't think actually
again I didn't think the same game was a
problem for me I see I was probably more
optimistic about my position than the
computer
um I guess I just thought by night on D6
would hold everything together and
um you know I didn't appreciate this
plan A4 until a little bit later like I
did actually
um at some point in the game I was like
oh yeah she can take on D6 and just go
completely changed you know Direction go
to the queen side and try to play
against the B6 pawn and the bad Bishop
on B7
um but okay yes you should have that
option
um she went to take this Knight and then
A4 and again you know I never actually
felt that I was doing so badly here
actually so maybe that was good like I
was a little
um optimistic about it yeah I mean I
thought my position was okay to at least
not lose right okay so um we keep going
and this is a tricky move Rook E1 yeah
and I played B5
so this was my first chance to really
break out with that pawn and using a
couple of tactics
um yeah like for example she could play
C takes B5 right Bishop takes D5 and you
know Bishop takes D5 Queen takes D5 and
then actually she has this rookie five
move which I kind of underestimated when
I first went for this line and okay I
mean I thought I had various yes Queen
D6 or queen D4 here
um they're even Knights E4 yeah either
Queen D1 or even Queen C7 I thought
maybe it could be doable
um yeah so I didn't think I was going to
be losing these positions but obviously
winning was going to be uh it's not it
wasn't gonna happen right so like here
she played the move F4 which honestly I
didn't see it all I thought it was very
interesting move very ambitious
um again you know creating problems for
me in my time trouble right because I
was already getting like kind of lower
on time than her and yeah I mean this
movement four of course it's very
double-edged like you can you can lose
after playing a move like that but I
mean okay that's still far away so she
Queen E5 this all of these were pretty
critical moments and I remember when she
went for like 94 yes
yes I mean none of that was obvious to
me at all like she played this move
actually pretty quickly and I just I
didn't quite get it because it seemed
like there were so many options and I
wasn't sure what she was going for
actually
um with this move like okay so I was
spending a lot of time just trying to
figure that out and I'd take something
she's giving up a park right so yeah
she's giving up a pawn and I mean I
always have this rookie eight idea I
mean I I guess that rugby one was her
point and actually you know what I
thought it was I thought maybe she
wanted to sack her Queen at first after
rookie ate uh Rook takes B7 uh and you
know because at first I was like okay
then maybe that's not so clear but then
in this position okay I didn't see F5 to
be honest that's an interesting move I
was gonna play C3
um but at least I realized he had D6
that I can go either G I can like start
with G6 and then go Queen d8 she's not
actually going anywhere with the pawn
and so okay like I I knew I wasn't
losing in this position which I at first
I thought like maybe that's her idea
um so then but basically if she doesn't
have this then her position is just not
very good after rookie eight because
um yeah she played Queen F5 interesting
wow I was doing that wow okay well at
this point just take on e4 and queen to
E8 that was computers yeah Queen E8
which we just bought this uh idea you
know I had I had this idea somewhere but
I where is the mate am I oh am I mating
with uh rookie two and then that's what
it is yeah you know what I just didn't
see that I was actually mating I mean I
saw these ideas but yeah and
occasionally you don't even go for the
mate you actually just exchange the
Rooks yeah and take the D5 pawn and that
you're simply winning yeah well I'm not
shocked I have something here it was
really complicated because I know we
were both in time trouble in this part
um so what did I do but still what you
did did not lose the advantage by it
yeah and rookie two I mean I have to say
I like that move a lot like I felt like
this part of the game I played pretty
well because you know we were down uh
you know to the last minute on the clock
and that's basically where I won and I
was shocked you know that she had this
transition to the losing the exchange
because here I just thought I'm winning
and and then suddenly she has this uh
she has D6 and I'm like oh I'm uh I have
to give up and thankfully thankfully
this is actually still completely
winning because of the pawn yeah
probably you're still winning yeah
handily but this one is easy Arena a big
big moment for you a big game for you
because this one was difficult one and
Jennifer you seems to actually be
winning her game uh against beg him
tomorrow you face Jennifer you yeah
that's a great setup isn't it
anything better I mean if you want to
win the tournament you get to play the
person who uh who is um in contention
for first place with you and yeah I'm
very happy I mean this game it's funny
because I couldn't win all my winning
positions in this tournament right but
then suddenly you win a position that
you really weren't supposed to win right
and that's kind of like a very nice gift
um so I guess I don't know maybe that's
the key to get worse positions or get
yourself into some some uh some trouble
and then you have better chances to win
I don't know Arena we're looking forward
to uh tomorrow's game thank you in a
quick question on sasia yes uh
considering the fact that you have not
such a great score with Jennifer you so
how how does it affect your mood if it
affects oh yeah not at all I mean those
kinds of things don't really affect me
um because you know we don't have a
great score that's just always a chance
to improve things and
um
and I remember when I first started
playing Anna in our first meetings that
we're also not very successful for me at
the very beginning of our rivalry but
you know as you kept going you uh you
just have a chance to turn things around
so I definitely
um I just feel really good about about
this game winning with the black pieces
against a strong player like Nazi and um
you know I feel like okay I mean I have
chances right I'm gonna you have to
remove the obstacles yourself if you're
going to win first place obviously and
I'm you know I'm happy for this
opportunity wow that's a great day
attitude something to learn here it is
thank you thank you good luck tomorrow
Arena and very good luck tomorrow as the
penultimate morale well wow to